oui
un quartier qui est l'image de ce pays
est en train de changer
cette banlieue industrielle dnc
annapolis avec ses usines et ses
travailleurs faisait autrefois la fierté
de ses résidents aujourd'hui le portrait
est bien différent
karoubi moon a perdu son emploi le
printemps dernier il n'avait jamais
remis les pieds sur le site de l'usiné
ex mode fermé depuis
venir ici me rappelle de mauvais
souvenirs ne pas avoir pu conserver son
poste
allen de dollars leur transférer au
mexique un salaire dérisoire de 3 $
l'heure le secteur manufacturier dit il
est ce qui a fait la force de notre pays
est aujourd'hui tout ça est en train de
s'effondrer un effritement que dans
notre choix avait promis de freiner pour
donner l'exemple
il avait choisi car ailleurs une autre
entreprise d'indianapolis
ici on produit des systèmes de
climatisation et de chauffage plus de
1000 emplois manufacturiers devait être
délocalisé au mexique dans notre chambre
a conclu une entente avec les dirigeants
de la compagnie des postes ont été
sauvés n'est pas tous
début janvier plus d'un an après cette
entente environ 200 employés quitter
curieux pour une dernière fois pour
faire part de leur mécontentement ils se
sont donné rendez vous dans un endroit
familier mare située en face de lusine
qu'ils avaient l'habitude de fréquenter
rené elliott est catégorique
ok je te sourit elle sait qu'elle ne
retrouvera jamais un emploi semblable à
celui qu'elle perd aujourd'hui plus que
son emploi franck staples a aussi perdu
son assurance santé
il a subi cinq interventions
chirurgicales au coeur ces dernières
années pour ses soins il a accumulé une
dette de 2 millions de dollars combien
d'autres ici franck s'opposent glam
l'alena qui a facilité selon lui les
délocalisations vers le mexique
là où les conditions de travail sont
moins bonnes et les salaires moins
élevés c'est justement pour éviter les
délocalisations comme celle qu'on a vu
ici que le gouvernement canadien plein
pour de meilleures conditions pour les
travailleurs partout en amérique du nord
cette idée est proposé dans le cadre de
la renégociation de l'alena aurait pu
plaire à l'administration américaine
pourtant les discussions sur ce sujet se
sont avérés particulièrement compliquée
cette l'idéologie et économistes
québécois marc bilodeau est installé en
indiana depuis plus de 20 ans pour lui
il est clair que bien des états
américains refuseront de se faire
imposer des normes de travail plus élevé
parce que c'est contraire à leur
pratique on aperçoit une course vers le
bord où il ya comme une surenchère chez
nous nous on est encore line diana et de
la partie même si son approche est moins
agressive que celle d'autres étapes plus
au sud
on vend entre autres les réglementation
plus restrictive pour attirer les
entreprises d'ailleurs tout changement à
l'alena ne devra pas nuire à cette
stratégie dit on indianapolis
un resserrement des règles du jeu
claires et il aux travailleurs salue la
proposition canadienne mais il croit que
ce n'est pas suffisant qu'il faudra plus
que pour sauver des emplois
les etats unis doivent carrément se
retirer de l'alena
la pression s'accentue sur le président
pour que sa promesse d'une amérique plus
fortes se concrétise surtout pour ceux
qui comme rené elliott ont voté pour lui
[Musique]
karim est né lui-même partisan de la
première heure de donald trump pour lui
ou si cela semble inévitable
l'administration devra poser un geste
très cogner pour mettre fin aux
délocalisations
mais à l'ena ou pas car beamon a fait
une croix sur son passé d'ouvrier à 63
ans il réfléchit maintenant à son avenir
question tourner la page il a vendu sa
maison située tout près de l'usiné
c'est ici qu'il a élevé ses enfants y
revenir rappelle bien des souvenirs mais
des bons cette fois ci
battre
très contente
mais il faut avancer dit il car beamon
entame une nouvelle vie laissant son
rêve américain
derrière lui